capitaine beaucoup de ja vu envisager de
venir ici qui peut Santa Clara Motors
TC les Russo vous savez qu'ils font des
histoires humaines avec une sensation de super-héros par opposition
à un film de super-héros sans
contact humain capitaine soldat d'hiver était un
peu le départ et essayait vraiment de
faire  sa propre marque et ils l'ont en quelque sorte
réinventée à nouveau, nous devons aller dans une
direction radicale si nous voulons faire
un autre film de Captain America, donc nous
préconisions fortement un scénario de guerre civile,
mais nous voulions que tout le monde soit à la
fois protagonistes et antagonistes
capitaine Davy doppelgänger Jerry bouge est
ton nom ce n'est pas méchant contre héros
c'est des amis c'est la famille c'est ce qui
fait de nous un bon conflit
dans ce film tout a changé les
nouvelles d'Ayana seront une nouvelle bataille aujourd'hui pouf j'ai
besoin de reprendre une colline
toi